AFTER A CASE OF PNEUMONIA
NEARLY CAUSED HER
TO COLLAPSE THIS PAST WEEKEND,
THE CONSPIRACY THEORISTS
OF TWITTER ARE CLAIMING
THAT HILLARY CLINTON HAS BEEN
REPLACED WITH A BODY DOUBLE,
WHICH THEY'VE PROVEN
USING A DEFUNCT VERSION OF
PHOTOSHOP
AND CONTROL V RIGHT HERE.
-(LAUGHTER)
-UH...
COINCIDENTALLY, THIS ALSO
HAPPENS TO BE A PICTURE
OF BILL CLINTON'S
WORST NIGHTMARE. UM...
NOW, COMEDIANS, ASSUMING
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE
BARACK OBAMA IS A MUSLIM
FROM OUTER SPACE ARE CORRECT,
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE DUTIES
OF HILLARY'S BODY DOUBLE?
KATE WALSH.
ALSO BEATING DONALD TRUMP
IN A LANDSLIDE.
-HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT.
-AH.
ALL RIGHT. POINTS FOR THAT.
JIM JEFFERIES.
UH, STAYING HOME
WITH BILL'S BODY DOUBLE
WHILE HE'S AT THE STRIP CLUB.
-HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
-OH.
MICHELLE BUTEAU.
SHE'S HER SECRET SHOPPER.
SHE HAS TO GO TRY ON
THE HIGH-WASTED PLEATED PANTS
TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S NO ♪ CAMEL TOE!
HARDWICK:
YEAH. PERFECT.
-CAMEL NO!
-HARDWICK: THAT'S IT.
-(APPLAUSE AND CHEERING)
-VERY IMPORTANT.
-IT'S LIKE A CAMEL HOOF.
-HARDWICK: ALTHOUGH
IT'S FINE
IF YOU SING IT LIKE THAT.
-THEN IT'S ALL RIGHT.
♪ CAMEL TOE... -♪ TOE...
♪ CAMEL TOE.
WALSH: EXCEPT IT MAKES IT SEEM
LIKE SOMETHING WE ALL
-ASPIRE TO.
-(LAUGHTER)
-WHICH WE DO. -HARDWICK:
I'M WORKING ON IT, YOU KNOW.
-BRING IT BACK.
-I TUCK IT UP THERE.
-I CROSS MY FINGERS, YEAH.
-THAT'S THE MOOSE KNUCKLE.
-MOOSE KNUCKLE.
-THAT'S WHAT I DO. NEXT...
NO, IT FEELS GOOD SOMETIMES.
IT'S LIKE I CALL IT A "FUDGIE."
-IT'S A FRONT WEDGIE.
-(LAUGHTER)
-IT SOUNDS DELICIOUS.
-FUDGIE.